[Music]
okay everybody I am so excited today
because I am joined by Caitlin Stacy the
star of smile which is out today Caitlyn
how are you doing
I'm good I'm a little traumatized from
having seen the movie a couple of days
ago
um I was just telling you before that I
woke up in the middle of the night last
night thinking about the movie and I
couldn't get back to sleep
um so I'm great but also terrible yeah
and I mean that must be a surreal
experience traumatizing yourself that
that must have been crazy right like
that's
well my I I just like I'm such a like
sensitive person like you're not in like
a good way like the 90s way when women
were like I want a guy who's sensitive
I'm just deeply like easily influenced
so whenever some I go and see a horror
movie people go in and watch them and
they're like oh that was cool and then
they forget about it whereas I whatever
I saw will live in my brain
forever and last night was the other
night was no exception and like even
though I know I was in this movie I know
these people I watch these things happen
it's still um it still really affects me
because also like not being able to
trust my own brain is one of my biggest
fears you know sure and you're right I
had that same feeling leaving this film
as well and I think that's why people
are excited to see this to really get
some true horror and Terror here now
what also has it been like for you you
have like this million dollar smile now
where you're really facing this movie
what's it been like being on posters
you're in insta stickers now what what's
that been like for you I don't know if
someone would pay a million dollars for
a smile like that but I uh it's been
really wild it's been
it's it's so funny you know because on
the one hand it's surreal but also like
I I it almost doesn't feel like it is me
like I kind of see them and I'm like hey
hey hey
but then I'm like oh it doesn't I don't
look like that every day so I don't know
it's kind of been normalized for me in a
sense and people were sending me
that you know that they they say they
can be too much of a good thing like I'm
I'm so deluged by the image of it that
it's kind of um
you know it's kind of lost its impact on
me a bit where I'm like well I deserve
this I deserve it
I love that answer yeah and I totally
get that and it's interesting because it
is so important that smile you pull off
and it really being the face of this
movie what was the process like getting
that smile down perfectly like did you
just stare at a mirror practicing your
days on end like how did you really know
you had found it yeah I mean I was
staying in this like Hotel in New Jersey
where we were shooting and like the day
before I was like how am I gonna do this
because like Parker has said if you're
not careful it can look really hokey and
like I think the I think that the um the
perfect balance is something that is
like
uncannily evil and friendly and kind of
funny at the same time because there is
this this movie's got a lot of humor in
it and
um and not just by virtue of people
smiling it's actually just very funny
and so it was just yeah me staring into
a mirror looking at myself and smiling
until I went okay we're good I'm done
this is horrible it's making me feel
nuts and then yeah I got on set and uh
Parker was like all right till your head
a little bit forward smile without your
eyes like widen the smile a bit and then
we ended up with with that horrible
image uh no and it comes off amazing and
it's impressive that you're able to
smile in a New Jersey hotel as well
that's yeah
in New Jersey I'm not sure
um now also it's crazy because you're
only in a few scenes here but they're so
important and so impactful so as an
actress how much pressure is that to
come in and nail such big scenes like
this
it was it was pretty scary yeah I had
had the the pleasure and the privilege
of being a part of the short film Parker
had made which was sort of like a
prequel to this feature and so
that short film was kind of
with the exception of like characters
switching out the the scene was
relatively similar if not exactly the
same
um but
so I I like I had reference I worked
with Parker before I had a feeling of
what he wanted
but yeah it's it you know I watch it
back now and like I'm I'm proud of
myself and I'm proud of my work but
there are still things that I'm like oh
I should have done this differently I
should have changed this a little bit so
there's always a lot of pressure but
it's actually great to only have
it's very rare to have a day dedicated
to one scene because of the nature of
film and TV now you have to shoot
several scenes in a day if you if you're
lucky usually you have to shoot about
seven or something so I am really
grateful that we got to do it more
slowly like that yeah and I think it's
awesome too because people see in this
opening scene it being with you and soci
bacon who are both just Powerhouse
actresses so what was that like working
with her and you guys kind of getting on
the same page there for that cersei's
great so she's so talented and I think
she like
Nails this film I was so impressed
watching her
um and being on set with her is really
Pleasant like she's like super
professional but really friendly and not
very precious and just yeah all in all
like a very safe very comfortable
environment which was great
yeah and talking about like safe and
comfortable environment was it also fun
in the sense that you got to be the one
scaring people on set like is there
anything better than being a villainous
part in your eyes no nothing better uh
there's a show that I've done that's
coming out in uh next year called class
07 we play a villain in that too and
it's honestly the most fun event I've
ever had like there's nothing more fun
than playing somebody with like Sinister
undertones being being the hero is is
great and all but yeah being the villain
is better oh hell yeah for sure and you
do such a good job and being that you're
this horror villain for you do you have
a particular horror batty you are a big
fan of in like the whole lore of Horror
yeah there's all kinds of oh God I'm so
bad when this question comes out but I
know that in my mind there are tons like
I love the original like Suspiria I
really love
um
cheese I'm having a hard time with this
question now I I mean like Rosemary's
Baby Oh yeah like movies where people
are kind of getting gas lit by everyone
in their lives and they're just like no
something's wrong everyone's like no
like The Omen you know what I mean yeah
I mean it's the same movie where
everybody's like what's going on with
you that's my biggest fear stuff with
some there's a conspiracy around you and
you're being made to feel like you're
you're not living in reality yeah
totally I I agree with that and it's
interesting too just talking about the
smile you're doing this to show the
level even on opening day like today how
it's already iconic before many people
even seen this film because you're
seeing with the marketing that your
people transforming the smile at
baseball games and at just news events
how crazy is that for you as well
because that's literally been like just
trending for a week now yeah it's wild
um it's so crazy I I can't believe they
managed to convince people to go and do
that at baseball games because baseball
games go for 12 hours
[Laughter]
I love that
um also too I think what comes with this
are people already asking you to do the
smile and if not are you ready for that
to come
um no one has asked me to do it yet
um I I don't know that anybody really
recognizes me from the poster maybe they
will from the film but but yeah I mean
I'm prepared will I do it for them
probably not you know what I mean they
want to pay me maybe I'll start a cameo
and I can just start setting them off
but the thing is available all over the
Instagram filters and like so I mean
they don't even need me anymore my image
has been taken and you know
no I like that you said the camera thing
don't give that smile for free they
gotta earn that
also
um you know you would mention another
show you're going to be in so in general
people I feel are going to fall in love
with you this weekend who see this movie
what do they have to look forward to
next for Caitlyn Stacy like what what's
on the radar here well I currently have
a show that's on epics it's two seasons
it's called bridge and tunnel if they
want to go back to the 80s that's pretty
cool and fun and then coming out ma uh
actually don't know when but I'm coming
out early next year first quarter of
next year 2023 is going to be a show
called class of 07 that I'm in with
Emily Browning and uh it's about a high
school reunion for a private girls
school and then the apocalypse happens
and then we're all stuck there together
and so I really love it I'm really proud
of it I'm dying to see it and I'm dying
for everyone to see it we shot it you
know from last year into March of this
year so it's a long wait a long
anticipated wait for it but I'm excited
yeah that sounds exciting so everybody
in the meantime watch Caitlyn just kill
it and smile it's in theaters now go see
it take everyone to see this movie it is
so scary and it's so fun and funny like
you're saying too and Caitlyn thank you
so much for joining me I hope talking in
the future and make sure you get some
sleep thank you so much
thanks Caitlin thanks bye